[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
John Smoltz is on the program now Hall
of Famer World Series champ former Cy
Young winner he'll be on the call the
World Series along with the play-by-play
voice Joe Davis game one between the
Phillies and Astros starts Friday at 8
Eastern on Fox John I've mentioned this
a couple of times you did a wonderful
job taking us through the at-bat with
Bryce Harper when he homered off Suarez
I also was wondering
as a former pitcher when you're on the
mound are you thinking the way a hitter
might be thinking
in those situations in the playoffs
the one thing once you've been there
done that you realize
that you you only are thinking well you
learn to think where can the damage be
done and avoid the damage so when you're
pitching in the regular season you
pitched a Scouting Report the hitters
are a little bit different of course of
course your pitching is going to be a
little bit different when you get into
postseason everything's is magnified
everything stops uh to think more and I
realized having gone through many
postseason games where that damage was
and what and where I didn't want to get
beat so I kind of
I kind of look at it from both ends what
a pitcher's strengths are and what a
hitter strengths are but more
importantly I learned you know 2016 was
my first World Series and that home run
off of Chapman was the exact spot where
that the only way he could hit a home
run to tie the game up and so those kind
of things you you learn once you go
through it but when you're in it for the
first time and you're pitching for the
first time everything is so fast it's
magnified and you lose that time and
space of the information that you're
given beforehand so that's kind of how I
look at it when I'm broadcasting because
I've been through so many of those
experiences before well we always talk
about hitters guessing do pitchers guess
yeah I think you have to I mean the the
problem today and I only say problem not
because it's it's
a real problem it's just there's so much
information that you can get overloaded
and you can either be a pitcher that
whatever they put down you throw
or you could be a pitcher that
overthinks having so much information
you're out guessing yourself so the
bottom line is if you're not totally
committed to a pitch or a location
usually bad things happen and if and the
same thing can be said if there's so
much information you're not following
what that hitter is doing in that given
day so that information might be great
over 162 but that given day his Bat
might be slow or he might be opening up
and the same thing for a pitcher if
you're a hitter you're trying to follow
what that pitcher's information is but
what if he's not what if he's his
slider's not very good or his fastball
you know so those things you got to be
careful when you're Gathering the
information that they're not absolutes
so that that day stands on its own and I
think we lose a little bit of that
sometimes when it comes to so much
information a lot of good information
but we got to remember that game is an
independent game of itself and not in a
bucket of 162. what's different about
Harper let's say now as opposed to three
four five years ago if anything
he's so seasoned
um he has been the guy that has learned
through his experiences right I mean he
was not right coming into this
postseason and you could understand why
he was hurt trying to regain a swing in
a short period of time boy did he get
right at the right time mechanically
he's connected now more than ever with I
guess you could say some of his
limitations meaning it's actually helped
him
go the other way swing big early try to
do damage early and then Lefty at bat
come to him so that he's not
um trying to do the same thing over and
over again and so that kind of scenario
when you get to the postseason and
listen nobody has had more on him
from an expectation standpoint since he
was thrusting this game
he's delivered under every circumstance
in Philadelphia on this Mega contract
that is just and it's it's impossible to
think that he could be the sole reason
that Philly wins the World Series but
you know what that swing gives them a
chance he's John Smoltz the Hall of
Famer if I would have told you a month
ago Philly's Astros World Series you
would have said
you're half right
[Laughter]
I mean the new playoff system really
this I don't think this will be the norm
I think last year the Atlanta Braves won
the most improbable World Series Ever if
Philadelphia wins you could say that
trumps it because they had an extra
playoff spot I mean round they were on
the road forever they had to beat some
pretty good teams to do that and if they
beat the Houston Astros you could make
the argument it's the most improbable
World Series that I've seen in my
lifetime because of the track of how
tough it was to get to this point and in
September how absolutely long shot they
were kind of like the Braves were last
year so it's it really is a credit to
how they have done this and not given up
hope and gained confidence in an
incredible way
is this a
all root for the Phillies because I
can't root for the Astros are we still
there you think with the the national
perspective on the Astros and what
happened a few years ago
we shouldn't be
um this is a great
this is the greatest way to show
yourself as an organization why that was
a blip and why now the consistency with
a different roster and different
narratives this is no longer part of
that narrative they have proven if you
want to prove whether it's an individual
hitter who got busted for
you know steroids goes on the rest of
his career he's clean and he has the
numbers he has that's how you answer the
critics what what I believe Houston's
done and Dusty Baker deserves such a
huge credit they've answered the critics
it wasn't a one and you know one-off
they have dominated with a different
roster and a philosophy that works come
post season it works and I'm telling you
this is this is how you answer it they
they did they've done an incredible job
are you all in on the playoff format it
felt it felt like well the Dodgers were
you know knocked out and then everybody
had a problem with the playoff format
I love it I think the playoff format
over time
look it's going to take a little bit to
see the the history of something when
you play 162 games you need to be
rewarded and this is a great rewarded
system for the two best records in each
league it just so happens that this year
the two best records in a national
league didn't get there
um everyone's talking about the layoff
everyone's talking about the differences
that have come that will iron itself out
I love the playoff format I would have
been shocked if you would have told me
that the potential first year we could
have a team that the last team to get in
to win it I think that would shock
everybody but in the future you're going
to see now what what Philly's done it's
going to give a lot of teams hope to say
whatever we need to do let's get in and
look at what Philly did look at what San
Diego did but for the most part I think
it's going to reward the teams that have
the best year and the best resources
because you've got a utilize a lot of
resources to beat those teams
if you were Aaron judge
you do what
uh
I can go to the Mets no
um
I could actually see a scenario where
the Grom and judge actually flip teams
which would really Set uh New York on
its ear no if you're Aaron judge you
know the biggest thing is is one of the
most pressure packed years uh is
probably the greatest time of the year
that you could have given the
circumstances of your conscience if I
said you could have degrom or judge for
the rest of their careers right now you
had to choose
uh yeah it really depends on where so if
I'm if I'm the Yankees uh you know judge
is probably the most impactful player
for not only your city but your your fan
base and and I think you got a surround
judge with a little bit more contact in
the lineup and then judge is going to
have a chance to win the World Series
look I I've been a fan of his ever since
he stepped on the field I think he does
everything in about the about the right
way you can do it we don't have a lot of
guys his size being successful so you
know as a broadcaster you don't really
root for a scenario but as as a fan of
the game which I still am I root for
players to a stay healthy and be able to
maximize their opportunities and he
certainly did now they'll talk about the
postseason a little bit but that that's
a microcosm of so many different things
you you want a guy that's going to show
up in the regular season and produce and
he did and uh it'll be interesting to
see how it plays out yeah I can't give
10 years John
no no no no no no I
I that with his age and his size and his
history will definitely reward uh one of
the greatest years I have ever seen a
player have in this modern era see I I
and people say is that the greatest
season ever and I say well is that
better than what shohei uttani did the
previous year
it's close see it's that argument stands
in a in almost like a a sphere by itself
because we've never seen a player come
close to doing what Otani did so Otani
is going to be that separate you know
entity until we get
um until we get someone close enough to
do to put it even in great you know
better perspective yeah I agree with you
I agree with you I think ohtani
um unfortunately this year he just ran
into judge
hey uh we'll be watching great to talk
to you as always safe travels to Houston
I appreciate it thanks a lot John Smoltz
he'll be on the call game one tomorrow
night in Houston eight Eastern on Fox